so I want to talk not just about this
book but your books because I like like
many others I've read many of your books
not from all but many and and Stewart
and I were involved with another
organization thirty years ago called the
Santa Fe Institute which was about
studying complexity and complexity seems
to be an underlying theme through most
of your many I won't say most but all
the ones I've a for example the recent
one prior to this is a book called
Aurora about a starship and things don't
go so well because systems don't
ultimately function particularly well
the palo political systems begin to
break down the social system the
economic systems all these things that
depend upon complex organic functions
self-organizing for the bottom-up as
opposed to human beings figuring them
out and making them work you seem to
have a deep suspicion of our ability to
understand and manage complexity oh well
we we we do pretty well in some ways and
then it's too complex to do really well
I you know I I'm an English major and I
write novels and the reason I write
science fiction novels is because I
think those make the best novels today
because we're in a science fiction novel
and so it's the best realism and so I
write on that was good better deeper
yeah all in a science fiction well we
are and we're co-authoring it together
and it's it's so it's a wild one
in fact it's getting weirder and weirder
yes every year which is kind of
beautiful and kind of terrifying
Hunter Thompson did have it right didn't
he yeah maybe but I I guess what I'm
saying is that I when you try to write a
novel
the cool thing about science fiction is
not only is it the best realism of our
time but it also goes beyond the
domestic realist novel of the mid 20th
century a kind of imitation high
modernism would say that it's always
about individuals all about characters
and it has to be stuff that people would
really do like on a college campus or on
an adventure somewhere this version of
the novel was individual an individual
story of a divorce
story of a person with Tourette syndrome
on and on it goes well the
nineteenth-century novel was about
individual and individual and individual
and society history and that's why the
big 19th century novel still appeal to
us and that's what this imitation
modernism lost and so science fiction
not only gets us back to the individual
individual individual society individual
in history but also individual and
planet and this is something that's
maybe a little bit new to literature
that that the novel would also include
the relationship between people history
and planet civilisation planet and
civilization as an ecological balancing
act so this is good this is it makes for
new novels it makes for big novels and
long vowels and so complexity comes into
it just as part of the novel be coming
back going back to its 19th century
sense of scale and and so I love that
part of what science fiction gives me
[Music]